il
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc
[Musique]
la statue était installée de façon
provisoire sur notre pari on s'est dit
et bien faisons une opération pour
montrer le patrimoine français
de l'autre côté de l'autre at an aux
états unis est évidemment la maison
france aux etats unis c'est l'ambassade
puisque c'est une partie du territoire
français donc nous avons avancé et nous
avons choisi ce moment avec trois dates
clés évidemment nous sommes le lendemain
du 6 juin donc de la date du
débarquement américain
et puis la statue arrivera à new york
bien sûr pour line defenders des du 4
juillet et après elle sera dévoilée
présenté dans la résidence de
l'ambassade de france pour le 14 juillet
comme c'est une oeuvre du patrimoine qui
est conservé par musée des arts et
métiers
c'est un prêt mais à près de dix ans et
évidemment après le prêt de dix ans et
bien nos successeurs parce que je ne
serai plus administrateur des cnam
verrons ce qu'il est ce qu'il faudra
faire mais je pense que voilà on peut
imaginer que le prêt soit prolongée mais
la décision de me va retiendra pas l
appartiendra à mes successeurs